maximum congratulations welcome back to
the show an important victory for you if
you wanted to keep touch with the
leaders how do you approach today's game
and how do you feel right now i feel
good because i actually i just checked i
played the perfect game which is crazy
i've never played the perfect game
before
because i actually during the game i
thought black had a draw but actually
says i'm plus 15 in that case so i guess
not a draw but i actually learned a new
opening system for this game
you know my opponent just plays
basically two different systems and so i
decided i'll
definitely
you know learn and just try to catch him
and i actually found a quite an
interesting idea which was only played
like eight times with rook d1 no
actually this early queen c2 earlier
yeah it's normal to castle but if you
play queen c2 the issue is the the black
takes on d4
uh there's actually some beautiful lines
uh queen c2 and the queen takes pawn uh
we just play rook d1
and after let's see queen c5 castles
the problem is that uh
there are no no normal
developing moves like for example bishop
g7 gets killed by knight g6
and then e5 and e5 yep but not even e5
bishop d6 first and then e5 now bishop
d6 first is like completely crushing and
then then e5 and then goodbye uh so so
black has to play so if the black can't
take on d4 he he's reduced to number to
some
limited things for example what he did
which is uh
you know he played the knight d7
rook d1
takes bishop takes and on bishop g7 it's
also possible to play f3 also
very dangerous for black but i decided
to convert the game into to transpose
that to the line that
that is unpleasant for black which is
after castles castles this position if
black spawn was still in c4 and and
white had opponent b3 then there are
other options for black like knight d7
or something but but
uh
but but now he's already committed
himself to taking on b3
um yeah and b yeah here on b3 black has
other options yeah like b4 maybe
but maybe most likely like knight d7
yes some weird things and then to
actually not when black takes on c4 to
take back to play b4 and take on h4
it's complete complicated but um
uh but black has more chances to
equalize but the way i played now that
we were surprised about is that uh b3
take take castle yeah you decided to go
castle instead of f3 yeah well
both are good you analyzed f3 as well i
analyzed both uh but castles the problem
with councils is he's played knight h7
against golden i think in this
tournament in fact like some years ago
but after the nation bishop g3 is the
key move very bad position so he had
this position before numerous times he
said i only saw one game but but he said
he had this position numerous times it's
a bad position and and uh i mean maybe
it's playable if black plays perfectly
but you have to really you know you have
to really try right but he played 98 in
the game after thinking for like 40
minutes so he obviously remembered you
know some some
facts at this point he spent uh
30 30 minutes yeah because they don't
because because of the move order
because he wanted to he was like hmm i
don't want this so then when i trade on
g7 and play five
okay this is an issue like okay the
problem is if i don't know one line i
saw and maybe it doesn't work i have no
you have queen h4 and and queen takes
pawn here
uh 94 98
uh i thought i play some move like queen
d2 for example
to come in and if you please let's say
uh f5 now well if he goes here then f3
and then yeah
but if he plays f5 i play knight f6
check
yeah maybe the queen has to be on c1
sorry queen on c1 uh not queen d2 but
the point is that knight f6 g3 queen hd
rook fe1 so
uh and and bishop and bishop f1 yeah yes
that was i mean i don't know if that was
good because you know
what do i know but um but it seemed
dangerous anyway uh yeah queen h4 knight
e4
98 queen c1 and let's get to the end of
of this game because a lot of games are
finishing up right now okay let's let's
put it forward yeah yes let's get going
with the moves from the game okay so
uh take stage g3 stakes yeah here i
thought i i thought he's okay but but
but i'm completely winning it's crazy uh
i thought he played well i was kind of
surprised about rook c8 i thought 25
immediately but queen f5 was the the
right movie instead of rook to c8 yeah
the only move and then black is like
just worse right a little bit worse but
probably holding on with perfect moves
okay very very difficult from the right
i mean yeah it looks horrendous but but
yeah at night yeah but here she thought
queen e5 b4 knight f5 and and i was like
oh my god should i take it no this move
is just but it's 97
well
yes but knight f5 well no knight five i
thought the frog d7
uh
yeah knight g3 no but queen h7 no no not
knight sir no then i thought uh
wait what more bishop c6 yes bishop c6
and i couldn't figure this out if rook
where if you take it for k7 then takes a
knight d4
queen h7 check i'll still meet huh
that's unplugged
okay so somewhere some night move before
that uh okay so that doesn't work okay
so that
rugby sounds like that but he did not
play that move he allowed you to uh
yeah so he basically just resigned with
bishop d5 it's basically the resignation
because like okay now what are they
what's the compensation max uh
first of all congratulations you're back
in the co-leading position at least
until the larry christensen game is over
who are you uh facing tomorrow uh
shabbat shabalov yes so interesting
that's a big one definitely but
importantly is what he will do today
against larry christians and we'll let
you go back to the hotel okay watch that
game get some popcorn going and get
ready for tomorrow all right
congratulations max